Osiris the firstborn son of Gabe a newt
Osiris was considered the king of the
underworld and a prominent figure in
Egyptian mythology Osiris is not always
considered a god many of the ancient
texts believe that Osiris was once human
murdered by his brother Seth Seth was
jealous of Osiris his power and
popularity and lusted after his wife
Osiris was married to his sister Isis a
custom that was common amongst most
Pharaohs as a God could only marry a
goddess Osiris made his wife the regent
of Egypt instead of set this was the
last straw for set he decided that he
would kill Osiris and take the power he
believed to be rightfully his
he held a banquet in the name of Osiris
and made the cedarwood
evany chest for the occasion he offered
the chest to anyone who could fit into
it however the chest was made to fit for
Osiris himself as he planned
no one could fit into the chest and the
last person to try was Osiris when he
laid down in the chest set slammed on
the lid and nailed it down he sealed it
with molten lead and threw it in the
River Nile the chest
eventually re-emerged this angered set
he tore his brother's corpse into 14
pieces and scattered them all throughout
Egypt once all the pieces of Osiris were
found and buried he was reborn as the
ruler and judge of the underworld
it is believed that Anubis who had reign
over the underworld at the time stepped
aside out of respect for Cyrus
of cyrus was considered a good and
honorable leader during his lifetime and
his presence in the underworld no doubt
gave people comfort he is usually seen
as a just generous and giving God
however there are some depictions of him
as a terrifying figure who would
dispatch his demon messengers to drag
the living to the realm of the dead
Osiris commonly appeared as a mummified
King he skin green or black to represent
the fact that he is dead he often has a
curved ceremonial beard a crown and he
signature flail his crown is usually
white sometimes with the plume of
feathers which are thought to represent
the cult of Osiris Osiris was also
considered the god of fertility in
agriculture he was able to grant life
from the underworld from sprouting
vegetation to the annual flood of the
River Nile
some argue that Osiris was a symbol of
resurrection and others saw him as
signifying the renewal of life in the
next world after the rule Osiris did not
rise from the dead there are rumors that
believe the ancient Egyptians were
cannibals until Osiris developed
agriculture and persuaded them to stop
there is no definitive evidence that the
ancient Egyptians were cannibals but the
legends state that Osiris brought order
to Egypt and established culture and
stability amongst the people it is
believed that Egypt was plunged into
chaos when Osiris was murdered only when
Osiris his son Horus defeated set and
took back the throne was harmony
restored
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you
if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained